[Music]
a defiant Dr Anthony fauci brushing off
the conclusions by the FBI and energy
Department that covid likely leaked from
a lab in Wuhan China
do you think we'll ever know how the
pandemic originated
might not it very well might not we may
not ever know that's unfortunate but
that's the possibility that we might not
ever know
yokonja is a Fox News contributor and he
joins us now so he's just going to keep
denying it Joe even Christopher Ray came
on our Network last night and had this
to say
okay the FBI has for quite some time now
assessed that the origins of the
pandemic are most likely a potential lab
incident in Wuhan here you're talking
about a potential leak
from a Chinese government-controlled lab
that killed millions of Americans
your reaction to all of that fauci and
Christopher Wray
Ashley it was so fitting that fauci did
that interview on Zoom right so he's in
one place somebody else is doing the
interview from home I felt like I was
back in May of 2020 right so it's it's
so fitting uh given the Optics and and
look Dr fauci likely has known this for
some time but dismissed it because NIH
funding for the Wuhan lab uh was
something that he obviously supported
advocated was behind and and the turning
point for some at least for me anyway
with Dr fauci uh who was a strong
advocate of lockdowns and masking
remember when he attended the first
Major League Baseball game played in
2020 I think it was July of that year
Yankees Nationals at in Washington and
there's this Infamous photo of him with
two other people in the stands literally
the only three people in the stands
smiling laughing and not wearing a mask
and when he was confronted on it he
didn't just admit that uh you know oh I
should have done that it's a bad example
uh to set uh you know he actually said
you know what I was just taking a sip of
water that that's very misleading and
most Americans looked at this and said
come on I mean you're not going to be
one of those leaders that are hypocrites
too and then we saw it happen over and
over again look the bottom line is that
most Americans looked at this and said
of course this virus that the world has
never seen came from a lab it happened
in Wuhan that's the home of the the
Wuhan Institute of virology the one that
you know studies bat coronaviruses uh
through gain of function that happens to
be located in Wuhan uh that created this
and and SARS Escape remember at least
three times from Labs studying this sort
of stuff in China before so there is a
precedent here and we know that several
workers from that Wuhan lab got sick in
November of 2019 at the onset of the
pandemic and I had to go to the hospital
with covet symptoms yet we still have
some in the media and late night
comedians like Stephen Colbert who
continue to insist that no it couldn't
have come from a lab it had to have come
from a bat in a wet market and now we
just know that just that it isn't true
based in basic logic yeah if not now in
the face of all of this evidence fauci
is never going to admit that he's wrong
and that's sad for our country uh
finally Joe want to get your thoughts on
this the supreme court hearing arguments
on Joe Biden's 400 billion dollar
student loan bailout but here's how the
head of the second largest teachers
union feels about it
all right this is what really pisses me
off during the pandemic we understood
that small businesses were hurting and
we helped them and it didn't go to the
Supreme Court to challenge it big
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it all of a sudden
what is about our students
they challenge it I mean that's rich Joe
Randy saying she's fighting for the
students seems like she took two years
where she didn't do that what's your
reaction to that spectacle we just saw
oh as a parent uh well let's put it this
way Mike Pompeo said not too long ago
that Randy Weingarten was the most
dangerous person in the world and I
thought you know in the world that's a
bit strong right I mean we got Vladimir
Putin Kim Jong-un and Prince Harry and
Meghan Markle I mean you know those are
dangerous people but most dangerous in
the country I mean as a parent who saw
my young kids uh in completely effect
ineffective remote learning learning on
iPads and and being in Mass for months
many months after the data and the
science said schools were safe Randy
Weinberg Weingarten at least is in the
top four seeds in my my bracket as far
as dangerous people in the country and
and let's put aside the fact that she
sounds like a hybrid of Howard Dean
meets Rashida to leave outside the
Supreme Court right I mean Red Bull
pixie sticks just completely insane
student loan forgiveness which is what
she was arguing about is a complete sham
it's an effort to buy votes because
nearly 50 percent of the loans they go
to pursuing grad graduate degrees you
know the people that become doctors and
lawyers the type of people who can
afford to pay their loan back I mean my
wife is a doctor she spent more than 10
years paying off her medical school
loans and and her retroactive check I
have a feeling is not coming so student
loan forgiveness it's only going to
drive up tuition costs loan there it's
only a temporary solution for people
many people don't need it and it makes
College an option for those who only are
in the upper middle class or upper class
while pricing out everybody else so take
a bow Randy Weingarten you're doing a
heck of a job when you don't have the
facts of the law you scream Joe Concha
thank you very much for your time as
always friend I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis